That is what happens when you target
innocent people, provoke sovereign
nations, attack them, and think you're
untouchable. Yes, you arrogant people.
You disgusting, arrogant individuals.
You think you can do whatever you like
and get away with it. The whole world is
woken up. And it is the beginning of the
end of Israel.
[Music]
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran, gives you reminders. Download
the Qurani app now and let it testify
for you on your makyama that you read it
wherever you was. Welcome to brothers
and sisters and dear friends. Iran has
launched another wave of ballistic
missiles. This time shaking Israel to
its core and it has hit an IDF
um hospital. It's not uh specifically a
hospital that cases just for the idea of
soldiers, but it is a um hospital that
heavily heavily deals with those
genocidal genocidal maniacs who are
being blown into pieces. Yes. Who are
being liquidated, okay? Who have arms
and limbs missing. Uh and may Allah
increase them in that inshallah who are
looked after in this hospital. So guys,
before we go to the footages of the IDF
building, um the IDF hospital that um
hosting these IDF genocidal maniacs who
were being liquidated, destroyed, um
this is TRT. And not only that, I'm
going to read you an article. In that
article, brothers and sisters, it's
clearly says to you that subhan Allah
that you are not allowed to record
because they know they are losing this
war and they are not allowing you to
record. And this the footage of TRT
before go to the IDF uh the hospital uh
that was attacked where it's around uh
the infrastructure of uh infrastructure
of IDF.
the the censorship directorate. We asked
them if we can film you and they said
yes. Sure, sure, sure. Here.
The Israeli censorship. I told them who
we are and I said I was wondering if the
press allowed to cover the attack on
Ramat gun and they said yes according to
we would like to go according to the
recent sensor guidelines. So we told
them that. Sorry. I want to speak with
him. With who? With your
show your your card. Your press card.
This is my press card.
So, you can see that they are stopping
journalists and anyone for that matter
from recording anything. Why? Because
they don't want to show the damage of
what's really going on and how they're
losing this war. Now, let's go to the
footage of the the hospitals being
attacked. And I'm going to show you a
map of how Israel is literally uh using
them as human shields. Look what they
where where they put their bases and
their military infrastructure around
hospitals. Every accusation is a
confession, guys. Here's the footage in
Let's watch that quickly.
[Applause]
[Music]
Hola.
Heat.
That footage you just saw saw there was
their stock exchange. Uh SP as you can
see on there you go. You know you just
think you think you can just you think
you just can attack people and just it's
calm. You just think you can just do
that in Gaza. They don't have the
capabilities of fighting you back etc.
You know and you think you can do that
to anybody. Who the hell do you think
you are?
Do you think you're going to live in
peace bombing neighboring countries,
sovereign nations, committing a
genocide? Do you really think the
arrogance that they have? And Allah
talks about them in the Quran. These
Zionists, Allah talks about them. You
know, their arrogance is their downfall.
The way they act, they act like they're
untouchable. They can do whatever they
like to whoever they like. It doesn't
work like that. And Iran has proven
that. Now the map that you see guys as
you can see here uh the Sora Medical
Center uh was um obviously affected.
Yes. But it wasn't uh their main set of
hits. So the as you can see those two
targets IDF um basis. Yes. Okay. Right
next to hospitals. For some odd reason
they could have fired anywhere else.
Yes. And you can see that and you know
very interesting brothers and sisters.
You know this is the Israel radar. It
says IDF analysis. 10% of Iranian
missile missiles fired so far targeted
residential areas. 90% were aimed at
military and other sites via N12 News.
This is coming from them. So, it's not
something they're making up. Iran is
directly, look at this, Iran is the one
that's the danger, but Israel the one
that has nuclear warheads. They're the
ones that actually have nuclear
warheads. And believe me, yes, go and
look at the Samson option. Yeah. These
guys, believe me, if their state comes
to an end, they will nuke everybody.
They will nuke everyone. Read the Samson
option, inshallah. Yeah. Okay. With
this, they do the opposite. with uh IDF
the scumbags they target 99% innocent
civilians and 1% infrastructure um uh
Hamas basis whatever now this is very
interesting so um we had Oruran
Marmustin okay so how it goes how I
explained to my 9-year-old daughter why
we had to rush to the shelter in the
middle of the night heartbreaking
obviously it's in I feel sorry for the
children that's going through this but
brothers and sisters even though seeing
this and nobody would give any excuse if
this was a case case of a Muslim girl in
a hijab. Who's his daughter? This young
girl writing signing writing her name on
bombs that are going to blow up children
into pieces. And now I don't blame this
girl cuz I could have taken another
stance and be very harsh and say, "Oh,
this is your 9-year-old daughter. This
is her, by the way." Yeah. This
9-year-old daughter. Yeah. Okay. And
again, I just believe they have been
indo indoctrinated. They've been
indoctrinated. They're fanatics. Okay.
They've been radicalized. I don't blame
these blame these innocent young girls.
Yes. Do you think I would want any harm
to come to these innocent? They Zionist
kids not at all because they are
innocent unless they grow up and make a
conscious decision of saying yes you
know that's a different situation right
now at this age we do not blame them
because they're young they're
impressionable they can be easily easily
groomed and you can see that is exactly
what is happening so this is 9year-old
that she's he's talking about sadly yes
okay and not only that brother and
sisters and we've got Hana Napali oh do
we all know this bastard yes we do the
Islamic regime in Iran targeted sleeping
families in Israel Oh, 10 killed, four
of them children. Disgusting and sad.
Innocent people dying in anyway. We are
morally consistent. We're not
strategically consistent. We're morally
consistent. And we condemn anyone for
attacking. And we know Iran is not
directly attacking civilians. But sadly,
you can see here that innocent people um
are dying. Yeah. And it should not be
the case. That should not be the case at
all. You provoked Iran. Yes. And then
you've got this little scum Maya. Don't
start a war you can't win. And if you
do, don't cry about it. It's as simple
as that. No problem. The same applies to
you, you dumb fool. Okay. On our way to
the shelter. What happened, Maya? What
happened? Yes. What happened? Subhan
Allah. So, you can see Bronx and there
is more footage.
[Music]
I call
the wrong
like the Old Testament says an eye for
an eye. You started this war in the
Middle East.
And some of even at least own Israelis
are mocking this. Look at the Israeli
comedians. Shalom from Tel Aviv. Today,
I'm giving you a guided tour of what
happens when you bomb other countries
for fun and act surprised when they
shoot back. Stick around. Next stop,
denial and international outrage. Thanks
to your support, we've been ignoring war
crimes since 1948. So, this is from the
Jerusalem Post. IDF sensor updates
restrictions on reporting
on reporting missile drone impact sites.
Okay. Any person who prints or publishes
printed matter or a publication
regarding the location of a strike or
hit by enemy war material must submit to
the military sensor for approval. Yes.
Okay. The IDF sensor uh head Brigen Kobi
Mandal may Allah destroy you into
pieces. A mean is sued updated IDF
sensor guidelines regarding reporting on
missile and drone impact sites in a
statement published by the government
press office on Wednesday afternoon. The
order requires any person who prints or
publishes um printed matter or
publication uh regarding the location of
the strike or hit by the enemy war
material including missiles of any kind
and UAVs in the in the media online
including social media blogs and chat
etc to submit to the military center for
approval before it is published. This
concludes both media published in Israel
and abroad. He clarified also Mandal
Bait also updated that he is prohibiting
the printing or publishing of any
publication that has not been submitted
to the sensor or which has been
submitted to him and his instructions
have yet to be received or have received
and not adurred to. Yes. So violating
this order is liable to severely
severely harm the security of the state.
He added stating that any violators will
be charged. This is a development story.
So as you can see brothers and sisters
they are basically petrified and they
are terrified that they are getting
this. They were they didn't they weren't
expecting this and not only that not
only that they are saying in the matter
of 12 days time there might be a total
collapse of this defense system because
it is costing them millions of pounds
millions of pounds not Iran because Iran
has drones that are you know 20,000
whatever it is it's not costing that
much this is a heavy heavy price that's
been paid and that is what happens that
is what happens when you target innocent
people provoke sovereign nations attack
them and think you're untouchable yes
you arrogant people you disgust
disgusting, arrogant individuals. You
think you can do whatever you like and
get away with it. The whole world is
woken up and it is the beginning and
beginning of the end of Israel. Brothers
and sisters, we will keep you more up to
date inshallah. Do not forget to
subscribe to Smile to Jenn to get
amazing updates inshallah and amazing
amazing information and data when it
comes to the recent attacks and the
conflict that's happening in the region.
to lie with Betto.